well I'm sure a lot of couples were
watching the return of 9:02 I know last
night the number one trending topic on
Twitter so when I spoke to the cast
yesterday I had to ask what would it
take for you guys to sign on to a season
2 I think it's just all about the fans
if there's an uproar nearly as loud as
what there was to bring the show to to
where it is today yeah then I can't see
it not happening nicely said another
thing we're all wondering what's 9:02 uh
no fact and what's fiction last night we
saw that happen but did Jason and Jenny
really hook up back in the day and does
Gabrielle swing both ways we really want
people to watch the show and be like
what parts real what's not real you have
to figure it out who's right and keep
watching and you'll know mm-hmm
well ET knows this for sure Shannon told
the producers they could do anything but
this my marriage was really kind of the
only thing off-limits
my husband was you know he's he's got a
career he's you know and he just looked
at me and said just leave me out oh and
let's leave Kim Cattrall out of any Sex
in the City discussion of another Sex in
the City sequel she has totally moved on
to her new Sophie drama filthy rich
these three will be no different
what I think people love about shows
like Sex in the City and and and filthy
riches strong characters and this is a
new chapter this is another strong
character so I'm I'm really enjoying
this and Jimmy Kimmel sure is enjoying
his Emmy love congratulations on the
Emmy nominations well you know for me
the most important thing is the awards
what does he think about Emmys show
going host free I guess it's like cars
where there won't be drivers anymore
will just sit in the back and until one
crashes I guess they'll keep doing this
let me show you what this interview
would be like if we had no host you
might step out for a second
yeah we're real excited about it seem to
be terrible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]